what is going on oh my gosh blu-rays
blu-rays you guys have been begging me
to make a blu-ray collection video for
some time since I made my last one I
don't have not sure you realize how many
I have oh boy
and guys I promised I would do that for
you and this video is going to keep that
promise let's get going with every
single blu-ray I own there's no way that
I can tell a story for every single one
of these this is going to be a
rapid-fire session of me showing you all
of my blu-rays and since I don't have
the greatest eyesight I had to wear my
glasses for this one so I can read each
title correctly because I'm old so here
we go alphabetical order
8 mile 10 Things I Hate About You 12
Angry Men fantastical to film criterion
collection twelve Monkeys fifty-fifty
101 Dalmatians and 101 Dalmatians 2 you
will see a lot of Disney films in this
video my wife's a big fan I like to buy
them for her and I like some of them to
500 days of summer
14:08 pretty underrated Stephen King
movie actually 2001 a Space Odyssey
classic both Ace Ventura films because
yeah just gotta have them what the hell
am i doing this is already getting nuts
The Adjustment Bureau the adventures of
tintin Air Force One Aladdin and the
Alfred Hitchcock collection for your
older film entertainment Alice in
Wonderland alien aliens all good things
not really that bad of a movie
interesting movie especially with recent
developments in the news all the
President's Men as you may notice some
of these I haven't even opened yet
because I just got them I haven't
watched them yet here Amelie my wife's
favorite romance film American hustle
American Psycho American ultra
and American Werewolf in London and
Amistad not American Amistad but I was
hoping it was just for comedy sake
anaconda my first ultimate guilty
pleasure that you will see and you will
see a lot more films like this movies
that aren't necessarily that good movies
I don't necessarily love but hey you
know what they're entertaining as hell
Anastasia
right yes Anastasia ant-man Apocalypse
Now
Apocalypto Apollo 13 Argo Aristocats
Arthur Christmas a AI artificial
intelligence Atlantis the lost Empire
and Milo's return Avengers Avengers age
of Ultron The Aviator awakenings
fantastic movie the babadook the Back to
the Future trilogy and Bambi okay Batman
Batman Returns Batman Begins The Dark
Knight The Dark Knight Rises Batman
Beyond return of the Joker and Batman
The Dark Knight Returns parts 1 and 2
Batman mystery of the Batwoman the Beast
rare Blu ray this was a TV special based
off of a what's his name Peter Benchley
book from the 90s hard blu-ray to fine
got it on eBay Beauty and the Beast the
beaver before midnight please release
before sunset the Sun before sunrise
already big fish big hero 6 The Big
Lebowski on my favorite comedies Big
Trouble in Little China Billa Ted's
Excellent Adventure Birdman Black Swan
and the Blade trilogy to be honest I
still have yet to watch blade Trinity
I've heard nothing but tear
things so it's sort of like one of those
things that I'm dreading that I hope I
don't have to do but I probably will
eventually we'll have to Blue Valentine
not a good Valentine's Day movie despite
what Walmart tells you every year when
it puts it into Valentine's Day section
bolt The Book Thief the Bourne trilogy
not Bourne Legacy which sucks Braveheart
speaking of Bourne I'm going to review
all those this year leading up to born
five looking forward to that brick is a
Canadian blu-ray for some reason brick
was not released in America but can but
Canada still has region one so hey why
not
haha here's another guilty pleasure for
you
ah bring it on I like this movie fuck it
I don't care I like it it's funny and
Kirsten Dunst is amazingly sexy in it
Broken Arrow incredible 90s action
guilty pleasure
Bronson Bull Durham part of Kevin
Costner's unofficial baseball trilogy a
bug's life The Cabin in the Woods Cape
Fear the incredibly terrible 90s Captain
America which may be a hilarious 'ti
review one day and both of the really
good Captain America's well at least the
second one's amazing the first ones not
bad captain Phillips Casino Royale
another Casino Royale steelbook I love
the look of this thing and even open it
because it was a Best Buy exclusive it
looks so beautiful
Casper that's the 90s kid in me
castaway catch me if you can
fantastic Spielberg film Cellular
underrated thriller have been watching
the wild ocean probably rewatch it
chasing amy really great Kevin Smith
movie chef Chinatown Christine Chronicle
Cinderella
clear and present danger clerks clerks
to Close Encounters of the Third Kind
Cloverfield clue such a good movie
collateral
all-time favorites commando get that
wrong la Conair I could say so much
about Conair most revolving a bunny and
a box conspiracy theory haven't seen
this in a while
underrated 90s thriller but maybe it's
not as underrated as I think it is maybe
I should we watch it I liked it when I
was a kid
contact Matthew McConaughey spice the
conversation maybe my favorite Francis
Ford Coppola movie and I know he made
the Godfather but I love the
conversation Copland again haven't
opened this but I have seen it really
good movie
Coraline Corpse Bride the crazies the
remake crazy heart Crazy Stupid Love so
many crazies creature another 90s Peter
Benchley movie that was brought to
blu-ray such a stupid movie but with a
great Stan Winston creature and Craig T
Nelson so you know why the hell not
Crimson Tide Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon oh my god
so many fucking movies ah let's go
continuing Cujo the Curious Case of
Benjamin Button dark blue dark man Days
of Thunder cheesy as hell Dazed and
Confused the Dead Poets Society The
Death of Superman lives what happened
thank you to Jon Schnepp for that
blu-ray deep impact another horrible 90s
movie that I own because why the hell
not and the departed certainly not a
horrible movie that was a great movie
okay let's get some more in my hand I
can't believe we're still in the DS The
Descendants descent don't have descent -
I'm not sure that's released in America
yet Despicable Me 1 and Despicable Me 2
I don't have the minions that movie
sucks dial M for murder and the die hard
films not including the fifth one
because that film doesn't exist dinosaur
the better version of the good nine
Sora just so you know the complete Dirty
Harry collection disturbia Django
Unchained Dog Day Afternoon Dogma donjon
donnie darko mrs. Doubtfire and you
bendin diet Doubtfire drag me to hell
dread I am the law
I am the law
that's the original one terrible i drive
drive steelbook very beautiful
collection and dual Spielberg's first
film see dumb dumb and dumber and the
mask Eastern Promises Edge of Darkness
edge of tomorrow edge of tomorrow Edward
Scissorhands the Emperor's New Groove
and Kronk's New Groove I love fuck is he
all these cuz they're movies and I like
movies hmm huh Empire of the Sun end of
watch enemy enemy of the state
entrapment Oh Catherine she touch oh Sh
there's a horrible Russian epic escape
plan eighty Oh more movies please in my
hand thank you
Evil Dead Evil Dead 2 army of darkness
Eyes Wide Shut face off it's like
looking in a mirror but not a faculty
fantastic mr. Fox it did to have Fern
Gully the last rain forest Ferris
Bueller's Day Off Mueller a few good men
you can't handle the truth Field of
Dreams hey Dad the fifth element the
fighter
Fight Club whoops I told you about Fight
Club the final destination collection I
own them all because you know who cares
around Halloween time I enjoy watching
these Final Fantasy the Spirits Within a
kind of underrated movie actually
Finding Nemo Finding Neverland a man
with no name double feature good to bad
and the ugly the firm flight flight plan
the fly Forrest Gump fracture frailty
alright alright alright
the French Connection a Fright Night the
remake from hell the greatest movie but
you know my wife likes it and I don't
hate it
the fugitive amazing 90s thriller the
game Gangs of New York gangster squad
get shorty get the gringo the ghost
writer the gift glory ah good morning
Vietnam Good Will Hunting The Girl with
the Dragon Tattoo
The Godfather collection Godzilla
4k remastered version this is a terrible
movie but it's entertaining as fuck man
is it bad the new Godzilla not enough
Godzilla still a well-directed movie
Goonies gremlins and gremlins 2
Goldeneye Gone Baby Gone gone girl we've
gone in 60 seconds Gran Torino the grand
master grand piano gravity the Great
Mouse Detective and Green Zone the grey
guardians of the galaxy the guest
Halloween Halloween - Halloween h2o used
to have the set kept the ones that I
liked the happening whole what a bad
movie entertaining as hell Harry Potter
collection haywire a movie they got a
lot of hate because people wanted Gina
Carano to make us very typical action
movie and it was actually better than
that the heat or sorry heat my apologies
the heat got confused for a second there
heavyweights Hellboy and Hellboy -
Hercules Hercules hero history of
violence home alone one and two shut up
Marv hook it was you who's yours Hot
Fuzz Hotel Transylvania give me a couple
more days and I'll have Hotel
Transylvania 2 House of Flying Daggers
How the Grinch Stole Christmas How to
Train Your Dragon
How to Train Your Dragon 2 Hugo Hulk wow
this movie is bad why do I have it it
was cheap as hell and I like making fun
of it sometimes I haven't even opened it
so that should tell you how much I
actually care the hunt amazing film have
yet to open it can't wait to watch it
again The Hunt for Red October the
hustler
the sequel to the hustler the color of
money identity the Ides of March the
imitation game no in the mouth of
madness I've found rated a carpenter
film a little bit inception ow
The Incredible Hulk with green
lenticular slipcover hard to find The
Incredibles Independence Day the Indian
in the cupboard
everybody in my school at my age
probably watched that in school
whoopsies the complete indiana jones
collection that wants to come out of its
container er there we go
and these were purchased because I'm a
collector
the trilogy steelbooks exclusive the
target I love them I'm keeping them just
in case they're rare one day because I'm
weird like that inglorious basterds the
innkeeper's the innocents inside out the
insider insidious and city is - city is
three insomnia - interstellar one of
these was a gift and one of my bought
for myself interview with the vampire
invaders from Mars childhood right there
childhood invasion of the body snatchers
the Iron Man trilogy the island one of
Michael Bay's not terrible movies it
follows the Italian Job Jack Reacher
Jackie Brown Jackie Chan's first strike
James and the Giant Peach Jaws Jay and
Silent Bob strike back
Jeepers Creepers 1 & 2 double feature
come to me blaze yeah hey Joe John wick
don't touch that guy's pets joyride
rest in peace Paul Walker Jumanji
childhood the jungle book the compute
the complete Jurassic Park collection
and because of my completionist all the
films on their singular blu-rays because
that's just the way I am k-19 the
Widowmaker many people don't know this
movie was actually directed by Kathryn
Bigelow Kill Bill 1 and Kill Bill -
killer clowns from outer space oh yeah
can the God and cop put the toy back to
the carpet bring it back
to the carpet the King of Comedy one of
Martin Scorsese's most underrated films
kingdom of heaven director's cut Ridley
Scott has actually gone come out and
said I should have released that cut in
theaters knowing whole interesting film
you know what I admire some of that film
there are some really great aspects of
that movie there's some terrible aspects
to particularly the way it ends in some
of the awful dialogue but it does have
some thrilling sequences and I got it
for like $4.99 I think Kingsman Secret
Service really fun movie Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang oh come to me movies movies are so
much fun oh don't fall okay oh that's
close Jerry Maguire and Jennifer's Body
almost forgot those meet the parents
Megamind memento don't remake my man
Hollywood you're so dumb don't remake
memento men in black Miami Vice not one
of Michael man's best movies but I enjoy
the cinematography Million Dollar Baby
movie made me ball I mean cry straight
up cry two copies of Minority Report
lenticular and steelbook misery this
one's for my wife the Miss Congeniality
collection I promise it actually is for
my wife she really like likes those
movies the Mission Impossible films
including a steelbook and mission
impossible 5 Money Ball Monster House
Monsters Inc monsters vs. aliens mr. and
mrs. Smith entertaining movie why the
hell not Mulan 1 & 2 The Mummy The Mummy
Returns mud alright alright alright
yes I'm gonna do that for every Matthew
McConaughey movie I don't care what you
think oh shit some of these are slightly
out of alphabetical order because I'm
doing these two shelves at the same time
instead of you get the point
Munich Mystery Men Mystic River the
natural the negotiator I have the creeps
Nightcrawler Nightmare Before Christmas
Nightmare on Elm Street collection No
Country for Old Men non-stop no one
lives saw this at the tiff premiere the
only reason I have it oh brother where
art thou and it is a kind of
entertaining movie um no one looks
oblivion oblivion oblivion Ocean's
eleven Ocean's Twelve just just shut up
Ocean's thirteen oculis another
underrated horror film I'm just going to
read these I know what you did last
summer I still know what you did last
summer LA Confidential labyrinth lady in
the Tramp lady in the water
fuck it The Land Before Time Last House
on the Left Last Samurai layer-cake The
Legend of drunken master lego movie Leon
the professional lethal weapon
collection
Let Me In liar liar Lincoln The Lincoln
Lawyer Lion King Little Mermaid Little
Mermaid - Little Miss Sunshine Locke
lone survivor who the lookout lupard
Lord the Rings trilogy The Machinist all
four Mad Max films Magnolia Mallrats Man
of Steel Mary Poppins The Mask of Zorro
Master and Commander matchstick men
finally on blu-ray matchstick men Matrix
trilogy maverick Odd Thomas on my wife's
favorite guilty pleasure movies Oliver
and company Fox in the Hound Fox and the
Hound - collection the one oh my gosh
the one such a cheesy ripoff of the
matrix and it makes me laugh every time
I watch it
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest one-hour
photo only God forgives the orphanage
the others the pact Paddington
ParaNorman 3d the patriot patriot games
payback
peanuts Holiday Collection um the people
under the stairs underrated carpenter
that is carpenter right Wes Craven sorry
Wes Craven rest in peace Wes Craven
Peter Pan cartoon as well as Peter Pan
live action The Phantom Billy Zane and
purple tights can't go wrong there the
first three Pirates of the Caribbean is
really the only ones I feel are worth
watching the fourth one yeah the place
beyond the pines Pleasantville
Pocahontas one and two Point Break Polar
Express a Police Story one and two the
new Police Story and super cop a
original poltergeist not the remake haha
a remake friender 3d and predator
predator 2 which i think is better than
predators sorry
predestination premium rush the prestige
presumed innocent and frantic collection
The Princess Bride and The Princess and
the Frog now to this side prisoners
prometheus proof pretty underrated film
you're gonna hear me say that a lot
Public Enemies pulp fiction classic got
to have it the raid 1 & 2 Rain Man
Raising Arizona all for Rambo films
Rango ransom get me back my son
ratatouille real steal wreck red dragon
rain of fire the rescuers 1 & 2
Reservoir Dogs requiem for a dream the
ring creepy movie the ring rise of the
Guardians Rise of the Planet of the Apes
dawn of the Planet of the Apes risky
business road to perdition Robin Hood
Robin Hood Prince of Thieves
robot jocks major guilty-pleasure here
major guilt service the rock another not
terrible Michael Bay movie The Rocketeer
childhood right there the rocky
franchise Rocky Horror Picture Show
Ronan the rookie rope rounders rumble in
the Bronx run all night the run down the
running man rush hour release rush hour
2 already please just release it for
goodness sakes safe pretty overlook
Jason Statham movie actually really well
directed for an action film salt you
know I haven't watched that a long time
it might not lectures much but I'll be
watching Sunday this Salvation starring
at Mads Mikkelsen
the Sandlot childhood right there
childhood Saving Private Ryan say
anything Scanner Darkly Schindler's List
School of Rock and Scorpion King some
serious guilty pleasures shit going on
here Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
The Scream collection scream for
secondhand lions movie for my wife she
loves that film life of walter mitty
somebody in my house must have watched
that and put it back crooked secret life
of sorry secret window 7 1 my all-time
favorite Seven Psychopaths Shanghai noon
and Shanghai Knights Shaun of the Dead
Shaun of the Sheep the Shawshank
Redemption Sherlock Holmes Sherlock
Holmes to the shining here's Johnny
Shrek 1 & 2 & only ones worth owning
shutter island' side-effects signs
Silence of the Lambs ah silver linings
playbook I'm losing it
Sin City sinister The Sixth Sense the
skin I live in Skyfall sleepers sleeping
beauty sleep be hollow snake eyes
Brian DePalma directed kind of
overlooked snowpiercer the social
network terrible cover but it is the
social network this song of the sea'
actually just song of the song of the
sea' sorry no the source code southpaw
spacejam childhood doesn't hold up as
well when Yuri watch it though speed
sphere also kind of a guilty pleasure
the spider-man trilogy spirit stallion
of the Cimarron spongebob 1 & 2 spring
horror film have yet to watch it was
very cheap and I wanted to see it spy
the original Star Trek film collection
the Star Trek next generation film
collection Star Trek and over here is
Star Trek 2 inner darkness
the prequel collection of Star Wars the
original collection of star wars star
wars the clone wars star wars rebels
state of play stir of echoes super 8
Superman Superman to the Richard Donner
cut and Superman Returns Superman
Returns Sweeney Todd the sword in the
stone taken the talented mr. Ripley
tangled Tarzan taxi driver the terminal
super underrated Spielberg film
terminator
Terminator 2 so the only Terminator
movies I have there will be blood they
live the thing on my favorites John
Carpenter version Thor Thor - Titanic -
my biggest guilty pleasure movies of all
time the Tomb Raider films love them
they're terrible
don't care Tomorrowland very well
directed movie third act in Top Gun
Total Recall the town and the Toy Story
trilogy training day transporter one and
two tons of fun
stupid dumb fun transporter three sucks
Treasure Planet the tremors attack back
trick or treat
troll two might be a hilarious 'ti one
day Troy
true detective season 1 True Grit The
Truman Show trust tusk The Twilight Zone
movie twister u-571 unbreakable under
the skin unfriended you know I don't
really have to own that blu-ray button
you know what I actually enjoyed that
movie overall unknown The Untouchables
up urban legend yet another guilty
pleasure that I like to wash around
Halloween time V for Vendetta Valkyrie
vanilla sky' a walk among the tombstones
war games
walk the line Wally
warhorse war of the worlds' warm bodies
warrior Watchmen the way way back We
Bought a Zoo We Were Soldiers what if
what we do in the shadows while we're
young
whip it whiplash
Who Framed Roger Rabbit The Wicker Man
oh so bad Winter's Bone I've never seen
that in theaters before I knew -
Jennifer Lawrence was like that girl's
good witness the wolf of Wall Street the
World's End wrecked wreck it ref the
wrestler the x-files films x-men x-men -
x-men 3 it's okay
not that great x-men first class the
Wolverine x-men days of future past and
the rogue cut of Days of Future past
Zack and Miri Make a Porno actually
haven't watched this yet
Zathura zodiac Zombieland and Zoolander
now for some collections the James Bond
collection every James Bond on blu-ray
all the way up to Quantum of Solace I
believe yes yes yes yes all of them on
there uh they all just fell up The Fast
and the Furious collection along with
Furious 7 and finally the entire x-files
show thanks to my wife she bought this
for me that's it those are my blue rates
now a smart I may have noticed there are
no anime films that were mentioned in
this video that is because all of my
anime is
downstairs that is a wholly different
video which I may do in the future a
complete animate collection of blu-rays
but those are all the blu-ray movies I
own would you guys enjoy this wow I'm
looking at them right now all over the
floor I'm like I have a lot of movies
guys seriously thank you so much for
watching this especially if you watch
the whole thing that's amazing I'm
losing my voice by the minute you guys
are the best thank you so much this was
my gift to you
one of my gifts to you along with the
upcoming Q&A for reaching 500,000
subscribers thank you so much for doing
that for me you guys are the best I will
continue to do my best to make good
entertainment for you if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
my eyes